It was unclear to me --
and, to me, this is sort of
the crux of the matter --
whether he actually got laid
or didn't get laid.
He was being
kind of cagey about that.
He said he had some fun.
He had --
That could be -- Second,
third base could be fun.
You don't have to get it
all the way in to have fun.
But why 2 1/2 hours?
Why 2 1/2 hours if -- if
he was just feeling her up?
And if he's just --
the whole time,
just in the back of his mind,
he's worried about his snake.
Yeah. You got a limp snake
in the bathroom,
limp snake
at the sushi place.
And the sushi --
He did say that, didn't he,
that they went to a sushi place?
There's a lot
of unnecessary detail
in that gentleman's
testimony.
And a lot of yelling.
So much yelling.
Sudden, loud outbursts.
It was like you were
at a Martin Sheen acting class.
I've never yelled that much
over $500.
Like, why $500?
It seems like
emotional suffering
more than anything else.
Yeah.
So, how do you know
how much emotional suffering
you've had?
I don't know.
Like, me being on here,
I feel, like, 100 bucks.
Oh, okay.
We can cover that.
So, not terrible.
Not great.
But what I would love
to see happen
is for them to reconnect.
And what better way
to do it
than over a fresh bottle
of Hennessy?
Maybe you award one of them
30 bucks, 40 bucks
for a bottle of Hennessy.
They go out, they buy it,
they drink together, reconnect.
How can you do this job --
How can you be a bailiff
and not be high?
Seems like a natural --
I never said I wasn't high.
I'm just not
smoking pot.
Oh.
I took a handful of pills
before we started.